my late nan was the type of woman
who could throw together an incredible meal
with seemingly nothing in the cupboard
and my favourite was always her Galette
and my take on her recipe
is gonna be my submission to the Wattie’s 90th birthday cookbook
if you wanna submit your own Wattie’s Creation
check the caption
A galette is like a free form tart
you can make it sweet or you can make it savoury
I start by making the dough
wrapping it up before popping it in the fridge to chill
while I get started on the filling
then we slice three red onions before popping them into a heated oil pan
and sauteing with some brown sugar and balsamic vinegar
until they start to caramelise
to that I add some Wattie’s Free Flow Spinach
and give it a few minutes until it's all cooked
Then you wanna roll your dough out into a rough circle
and the best thing about this dish is the more rustic it looks
the better so it doesn't need to be perfect
pile on your filling leaving a bit of a border around the edge
and I'm topping that with a can of Wattie’s Sliced Beetroot
toasted walnuts, feta and a drizzle of honey
or hot honey if you're feeling spicy
and then you wanna kind of fold the pastry in to create almost like little pleats
brush it with an egg wash
bake it and then top with fresh thyme
this dish is quick easy and flavoursome
and you can find the full recipe down below